well as you know Thanksgiving is next  week today Project 150 getting a head  start on spreading some holiday cheer So  Yesterday packaged more than 2 000 meals  for homeless displaced and disadvantaged  high school students here in the valley  each meal will feed a family of four and  included well it's just a full  Thanksgiving feast  the reaction is amazing so it's mixed  with smiles and tears everything is just  out of gratitude they're so grateful  that someone thought of them and it took  the time to hand pack these boxes for  them project 150 does great work here in  the valley meals will be delivered to 75  Clark County high schools today the  organization serves another meal for  Christmas as well we have information on  how you can help eightnewsnow.com